Nobel Peace Prize winner Malala
yousufzai has a new book highlighting
the stories of young women impacted by
global immigration policies it is called
we are displaced my journey and stories
from refugee girls around the world in
it she tells her own story of
displacement after being shot and nearly
killed by the Taliban in her home
country of Pakistan she also shares the
stories of other displaced women she's
met
they include Marie Claire a refugee who
escaped violence in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and Zambia before
moving to Lancaster Pennsylvania and
Anna Lisa who fled Guatemala and made
the dirt dangerous journey across the
us-mexico border to Massachusetts in
search of a better life Malala yousufzai
is here for an interview you'll see
first on CBS this morning good morning
Malala good morning this is such an
important topic because we have the most
refugees in the world since World War
two and you are a refugee since when you
were a child even before you were shot
yes the number of refugee has been the
highest since the Second World War and
this is a current issue and often time
when we hear about refugees we heard
about them in figures and numbers and we
hear about them but we need we never
hear from them we never hear what they
want to say what their dreams are what
their aspirations are and I have met
many refugees in refugee camps around
the world and you know just seeing how
how like ignorant some people are or how
people do know enough enough about these
these issues so I decided to write this
book and hope that people will learn
more about refugees and hear from them
well because you want people to know
that these are human beings with hopes
for a better future and that this
evacuation in many cases was not a
choice it was a matter of survival
can you talk about that a little bit
well first of all I think about my own
situation in Swat Valley when the
Taliban came to our Valley took away our
education they bought more than 400
schools they took away peace from us and
our last choice was to leave and for
most of these girls
most of these women and children around
the world who are going through
conflicts right now going through Wars
right now they're the last choice is to
become refugees but that's often the
only choice to survive and they want you
know to live in a peaceful place they
want to have a home they want to have a
future for their children and that's
often the things that we don't hear and
and I think that's that's something that
I want people to understand that I want
to deliver through this book alala you
were shot because you were speaking up
about girls education and the importance
of girls being educated in school and
you were still speaking up about that
yes because you know I wanted my right
to study I wanted my right to become who
I wanted to be and this is the struggle
of all those people who are going
through these conflicts right now you
know the girls I mentioned from Maria in
Colombia is she she is also making
documentaries spreading the message
across there are many girls like Mouzone
whose story I also shared from Celia she
is now an ambassador for Syrian refugee
children and speaking out for them so
it's important for us to understand how
people in those areas won't change they
want peace in their area they want yes a
lot of the displaced people are trying
to make it to America what does America
look like for them well the people who
leave their countries they hope that
America would be a welcoming country
just like you would welcome any guest to
your house who need some shelter who
need some love and support so I think
that's the expectation that they have
from America and from any other country
you know some girls are moving from like
Congo didn't Zambia then to the US and
they have this hope that they'll finally
CPS they'll finally receive love and
support and the people of the u.s. they
are very you know warm welcoming they're
they understand what it is like to be a
refugee to be an immigrant but we don't
know the story of annalisa I mean there
are 300,000 people a year from Guatemala
El Salvador Honduras that are trying to
come and leave their countries for a
better place and annalisa describes a
border facility that she spent time with
and then while trying to get in the
United States as a dog pound
what did she say about her experience
anna-lysa shares a story of crossing the
border and you know recently seeing in
the news how refugees and how immigrants
are treated at the border I think it's
just shocking how this fifteen-year-old
girl who has this dream to see her
brother to see some safety she has lost
many things are in her life and then she
comes to a border and she does not
expect this she thinks that you know
people would welcome her with a smile
with an open heart and and just you know
getting trapped on the border and seeing
that you know this was not what she had
hoped for I think it's quite shocking
and the thing that we cannot imagine no
we have never thought about that life
living in in a war and then crossing the
borders and I think the president wants
to put up a border wall what message do
you think that sends this is this does
not reflect America this does not
reflect the values of America and I hope
that the President and also other
political leaders in the US they you
know reflect what American people
believe which is welcoming in which is
supporting refugees and I hope the
president and other people read the book
and learn more about refugees and I also
hope that they visit a refugee camp and
actually meet refugee people and hear
their stories when he is in Molalla
quickly why was it important for you to
talk about people like Jennifer in the
United States who helped foster these
refugees the marie-claire from the
republic of congo why was it important
to tell her story I think we don't hear
more more about the people who are
actually doing so much work for Refugees
there are organizations there are local
leaders and activists and jennifer is
one of them she has given so much of her
time and her life to this cause you know
she's helping them get their education
she's helping them to go shopping she's
helping them to learn the new language
and about the culture and she's helping
them find jobs and all these things are
helping these refugee girls and to
adjust this new environment she has
helped Mary Claire and many other young
girls and boy
out there and when I met her was truly
inspired by her story so I want people
to get inspired from her story and do
the same as her well the good news is
there are a lot of Jennifers and you're
a second year student at Oxford are your
grades we are a dis place goes on sale
tomorrow wherever you like to buy your
books